there's millions of people around the
world who want my signature and want a
picture with me and I'm just like some
normal person SK Telecom I'll just roll
it through the Nexus turrets are
potentially going to go down this could
be a 20-minute game for sk telecom they
will be the season 3 Wow champions here
at the staple center welcome to the
League of Legends the current champion
of the competitive video game world it's
a computer game that five players are
teammates just like any other team sport
play against another five people some
would say it's like chess you might not
have as many pieces as in chess but you
control like one really strong piece
everyone's always moving around and
trying to outsmart each other but in the
end you're just trying to destroy the
enemy's pieces and there's just so much
strategy and thinking about there's nine
other people that you're playing with
and you have to account for them at all
times and if you forget for a single
second what one person is doing you
might get caught off guard surprised and
killed with over 40 million regular
players 1 billion hours of log gameplay
and 70 million unique accounts league of
legends has become the fastest growing
game in the world in fact it's so
popular it has its own pro division
complete with salary athletes diehard
fans and massive corporate sponsors why
is it grown so fast because for League
of Legends the community is key league
of legends from my personal opinion has
done so well is because first they built
a game that was really really fun and
and then they respected the community
and they they listened and they took
feedback from pro players and people
that played their game and then they
adjusted it and they kept getting it
better and better and better and then
they were I believe one of the first
developers to actually say you know what
let's put a lot of money behind making
this a spectator sport let's hire the
the best production people to have a
stage that in a production value that
parallels the NFL or watching a
basketball game let's put shout casters
let's put the right video let's put the
right stage in place let's let's have a
soup
hi professional quality associated with
eSports that had never been done
previously so is the League of Legends
success of fluke or will the world of
eSports continue to grow I absolutely
believe eSports will grow and the reason
why I say that is because just the aging
of the population right you've got your
Millennials that are just accustomed to
growing up on iPads and PCs and consoles
and it's second nature right and there's
not as many of those kids that are
growing up on antennas and football and
traditional sports it only makes sense
that you begin to recognize or
appreciate the athleticism in certain
individuals at five video games so that
appreciation comes from these
Millennials that are coming into the
industry and now they want to watch
sports that they grew up with things
that are nostalgic to them things that
they appreciate so just from a numbers
standpoint absolutely there's going to
be no people to appreciate eSports and
enjoy watching it as a spectator sport
the reduction cost and bandwidth that is
allowed people to stream online for us
to broadcast LCS worldwide and have
500,000 people tuned in concurrently
these are that kind of technology and
the cost associated with it wasn't
around 10 years ago whether it's a flash
in the pan or a sign of the times league
of legends has the attention of the
Millennial
it is a legitimate sport and there are
millions of fans around the world who
pay good money to watch you play and
there's a bunch of sponsors around the
world who paid thousands and thousands
of dollars every month just to put their
name on your Jersey like this so it's
it's a big thing and it's legitimate